[Musica]
oggi vogliamo raccontarvi una fiaba
moderna in un giardino di periferia ma
quale io starei mica parlando del parco
di cosi johnson di case finali quello
coinvolte nel progetto green city del
comune di cesena si si proprio quello ma
femme iniziare raccontare cosa succedeva
lì c'erano un sacco di stracci vecchi
abbandonati a terra vecchi f colorate
che avevano delle belle fantasie ma che
così prive di orly e forme definite non
servivano a nulla le attendevo un solo
destino quelle di finire nel cestino ma
e queste feste con le rotte non saranno
mica tutte le potenzialità che il mondo
dell'educazione in serbo ma che non
riesce a sfruttare a dovere
mi sa proprio di sì ma aspetta che ti
spieghi meglio in quel parco c'era poi
un grande albero che si sentiva solo e
aveva freddo perché nel punto in cui era
nato soffiavano sempre due forte
correnti d'aria che gli scompiglia vano
la chioma
ah ecco vedi il grande albero è davvero
la scuola di giardino stree con tutte le
sue risorse ma anche le sue mille
criticità il grande albero è
l'educazione non efficace quella che non
riesce ad appassionare come dovrebbe le
nuove generazioni dai ma non rovinare
tutto così sei proprio fastidiosa è lo
sa la verità è un po scomoda sai a
famiglie e ferri chirurgici fa male ma
guarisce quelle correnti d'aria
tutto sommato facevano compagnia
all'albero ma non proprio nel modo in
cui lui avrebbe voluto loro avevo nel
brutto vista e di essere un po sfuggenti
arrivavano ma poco dopo se ne andavano e
l'albero non riusciva a quasi ma
scoprire chi fossero veramente le due
correnti d'aria dal canto loro avevano
per natura una grandissima energia e non
disturbavano l'albero di proposito
loro erano un po disorientate quasi
spaventate dall'immensità del cielo in
cui potevano muoversi e cercavano uno
spazio più contenute e intimo dove
sentirsi a casa ma fanno un po
indovinare secondo me quelle due
correnti d'aria si chiamano arte e
didattica e si sentono un po
disorientati
allora mi educativo di oggi non riescono
ad esprimere al meglio il loro
potenziale
eppure loro vorrebbero solo poter essere
d'aiuto alla scuola e insieme a lei
formare giovani in maniera più creativa
e innovativa è sì in effetti non posso
proprio darti torto parli un po troppo
mai capito tutto
ma spetta andiamo avanti un giorno nel
parco passarono per caso due amiche
avevano lunghi capelli biondi grandi
occhi chiari e luminosi un sacco di idee
per la testa e soprattutto una gran
voglia di fare qualcosa di bello ha
finalmente ci siamo anche noi con le due
amiche siamo propri e te
che bello pensare al momento in cui
abbiamo deciso di tradurre in realtà le
nostre idee e di unire i nostri due
ambiti di competenza
l'arte da didattica in questa strepitosa
avventura dai fame.la raccontare però
questa avventura come vivere gli stracci
abbandonati sull'erba
l'albero è tutto solo un po triste e le
due correnti d'aria fermentare sì quella
è velo di colpo l'idea geniale
chiamarono all'appello l'arte la
didattica e gli affidarono un compito
dovevano utilizzare le loro energie per
ripulire il parco risucchiare tutte
quelle vecchie pezze colorate in una
sorta di piccolo uragano di bellezza
l'arte la didattica entusiaste di essere
guidati da qualcuno che finalmente si
curasse di loro fecero sollevare a
mezz'aria gli stracci abbandonati questi
iniziano a girare su se stessi ea
mescolarsi fra loro ma non ci credo
qui gli spazi colorati sono proprie
teste che abbiamo recuperato nelle
nostre cantine nelle nostre soffitte e
le abbiamo fatte tornare a nuova vita
per dimostrare a tutti che la bellezza
in fondo può nascere ovunque sono
piuttosto delle scelte le idee a fare la
differenza
a quel punto però occorreva andare al
soccorso anche del povero albero
le due amiche allora prendendo lago
della curiosità e il filo magico della
creatività iniziarono a ricucire le
tette in un magnifico vestito che
calzava a pennello per il tronco
dell'albero ma ti ricordi che bello
fuggire quel coloratissimo vestito
intorno al tronco e dell'audio
l'aiuto delle nostre nonne e poi tutto
il vicinato curioso di capire che cosa
stessimo combinando sia una gran bella
emozione ma ancora dobbiamo raccontare
un sacco di cose
l'arte la didattica rimaste intrappolate
fra i morbidi e colorati tessuti degli
stracci si sentivano finalmente al
sicuro in quel bell'abito a stretto
contatto con l'accortezza ora riuscivano
a confidarsi ben bene con l'albero
facevano delle lunghe chiacchierate
condividevano un sacco di idee e
pensieri interessanti l'albero degli
stracci così adesso si faceva chiamare
non aveva più freddo e aveva perfino
voglia di sorridere è certo che l'albero
re felice da quel momento è diventata la
sede delle nostre attività didattico
artistiche che hanno guidato i bambini
alla scoperta dell'arte e di tante altre
tematiche permettendogli non solo di
imparare facendo ma anche di divertirsi
la chioma dell'albero infatti inizia ad
arricchirsi di nuovi rami che diventando
sempre più lunghi si moltiplicavano
all'infinito
nascevano sacco di foglie dai colori e
dalle forme diverse c'era quella che
ricordava una cartina geografica
una figura geometrica quella che
sembrava una nota musicale una lettera
dell'alfabeto un numero pareva che non
avessero nulli in comune eppure
nascevano tutte dallo stesso ramo che a
sua volta era ben salda al tronco
coccolate dall'arte e dalla didattica
eh sì perché è una didattica di successo
non può non basarsi sui collegamenti
interdisciplinari sta per mettere in
connessione le idee permette di
acquisire consapevolezza e quindi di
interiorizzare realmente i nuovi
apprendimenti e l'arte nel raggiungere
questo obiettivo può esserci di
grandissimo aiuto perché racchiude
naturalmente in sé molto di più di
quello che solo si vede del resto l'uomo
nel corso della storia e ancora i giorni
nostri comuni che attraverso l'arte un
sacco di tematiche che i bambini quindi
possono scoprire in maniera più
accattivante proprio mettendo le mani in
pasta
non ho ancora svelato il finale che da
vuoi dire la morale allora dov'eravamo
rimasti
quell'albero con il vestito i capelli
variopinti divenne presto così tanto
bello che attirò l'attenzione di tutti
gli animaletti degli scoiattoli degli
uccellini troppo curiosi di esplorare
tutti
cb le vie del suo magico labirinto di
rami e saperi si divertiva ma giro
magari all'interno di quella chioma così
enciclopedica e giocando a rincorrersi
ogni volta si imbattevano in una nuova
scoperta e subito dopo in un'altra le
ore passavano e loro nemmeno se ne
accorgevano ma che bello vedere i
bambini appassionarsi ogni giorno di più
la forza motrice più potente della
conoscenza è la curiosità ed è proprio
educando alla bellezza che ti si può
impegnare a crescere nuove generazioni
non soltanto capaci ma soprattutto
sensibili ma in tutto questo parlare non
vuoi sapere che fine hanno fatto le due
amiche dai dai dimmi un po anche se
forse mi viaggiate l'on.le premier che
sedute sull'erba osservavano da lontano
quel bellissimo spettacolo e non
potevano credere di aver portato nel
parco l'arcobaleno si erano divertiti e
cercare di cambiare il destino di quel
giardino c'erano riuscite e adesso non
vedevano l'ora di provare a travolgere
la vita di qualche altro albero infelice
insomma ormai forse l'avrete capito
l'albero degli sprazzi non essere una
fiaba per bambini ma un progetto
ambizioso per adulti creativi che amano
dare un senso alle cose e vogliono
guidare i più piccoli a fare lo stesso e
quelle due amiche siamo proprio noi
martina e brenda nate cresciute a cesena
con un sogno nel cassetto quello di
conservare la nostra inguaribile
attrazione per le cose belle quelle che
non solo fanno bene agli occhi ma
soprattutto al cuore l'albero degli
sprazzi è stata per noi la nostra più
preziosa esperienza a km zero una sfida
che sa permesso di capire che dare forma
concreta le proprie idee è realmente
possibile
siamo felici di aver fatto qualcosa di
bello per la nostra città ci siamo
divertite a vedere guardando i bambini
divertirsi appassionarsi incuriosirci e
da lì abbiamo deciso di non fermarsi più
del resto una storia veramente bella non
solo se un lieto fine ma soprattutto se
regala un nuovo inizio
e infatti ne abbiamo combinate tante
altre ma quelle magari ve lo raccontiamo
un'altra volta prima di salutarvi però
una cosa vogliamo proprio dirla sognate
in grande perché come qualcuno diceva
nessun sogno è mai soltanto un sogno
[Musica]